est-ce que la cigarette électronique est
vraiment efficace pour cesser de fumer
la réponse longtemps tendu nous vient
d'une étude britannique
si oui c'est une bonne nouvelle parce ça
confirme ce conseil depuis sept huit ans
que la célérité et tonique est un très
bon moyen pour arrêter de fumer
l'étude suivait près de 900 fumât durant
une année
résultat la cigarette électronique s'est
montré deux fois plus efficace que les
produits antitabac classique pour ce
défenseur du vha potage ces résultats
arrive au bon moment
malheureusement à cause de toute la
publicité négative
les études mal faits qui sont toutes les
trois semaines pour des écrits très
dangereux pour la santé
l'esiea tectoniques beige et des
patients moteurs ont repris le fier et
ce je vous avoue que ça choque pas mal
l'envers de la médaille
80% des participants qui ont cessé de
fumer un vapo t'en va pas tu es toujours
à la fin de l'étude
un phénomène très répandu semble-t-il
vous n'avez pas l'impression que vous
n'êtes pas aussi d'une dépendance à une
autre dépendance plus ou moins le
cessionnaire l alternative jeudi à g qui
a pas de dépendance
les statistiques indiquent également que
beaucoup d'utilisateurs de cigarettes
électroniques continuent de fumer du
tabac à l'occasion particulièrement les
américains c'est sûr tu peux alterner
légèrement au départ on n'est pas tous
pareils ça que ça dépend pour chacun
moment c'était vraiment rapide jean
suffire devant ces faits certains
spécialistes demeure méfiant
ce qu'on sait c'est que la cigarette
électronique sans présenter des risques
pour la santé cardiovasculaire oui et
qu'elles présentent aussi des risques de
maladies pulmonaires comme l'asthme et
la bronchite
donc ce n'est pas un produit inoffensif
selon le conseil il serait prématuré
d'en faire un traitement antitabagique
de première ligne remboursés par le
gouvernement et il faudra aussi à ce
moment là comme les autres thérapies de
remplacement nicotine que la cigarette
électronique soit vendue sous
prescription médicale et enfin voici
seulement alors que c'est pas du tout le
cas actuellement
c'est pas la solution de médicaliser les
cigarettes électroniques
je pense que monsieur tout le monde se
met à tout le monde qu'ils font
c'est très à l'aise moi qui avais
s'acheter des cigarettes électroniques
plutôt que un paquet de cigarettes
conventionnelles ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal